hey guys i am back on the road doing
live stand-up comedy shows and it has
been a blast thank you to all the slugs
that have come out and i cannot wait to
meet the rest of you
you can see me next at flappers comedy
club in burbank california
july 15th in utah salt lake city
wise guys july 16th through 17th the
tempe improv in arizona
august 6th through 8th caroline's on
broadway in new york city
august 12th through 14th bakersfield
california at the trembler
brewing company august 21st um and
hartford connecticut at the funny bone
august 27th through 29th
a lot more dates are coming up so check
those all out at annie letterman.com
and my dear friend esther pavitzky you
may know her as little esther
or little edgar has her very own
clothing line
she has casual comfortable sweats called
sleepover by esther and they are
available
at sleepoverester.com sleepover by
esther.com thank you
sleepover by esther excuse me we have
some really cute drops that i think are
available right now
kristen dunst do you remember she was
like kirsten dunst kirsten dunst oh my
god do you know her
no she was in a workout class once she
has such a good body she really has
ultimate body but she
was a small child and she kissed brad
pitt and i remember them being like it
was her first kiss of course she was
like really
she was i don't know eight years old or
something she was maybe like 10.
and i remember all the interviews were
like
oh my god what was it like to kiss brad
pitt it's like ew leave her alone she's
a small child and he's a grown-ass man
that would not fly today no it's weird
how much
how disgusting everything is did you see
the thing with billy eilish that
happened
no where she so you know she's always
wearing like really baggy clothes and
stuff like that and she was like what 17
15 when she started
and now she's 23 or 22. and she did some
sort of
magazine cover where she was like sexy
and
she's getting backlash from all these
people that were like but you were like
someone that didn't care about your body
and stuff like that it's like
or maybe she was a [ __ ] kid not
trying to [ __ ]
and then now she's an adult and is like
allowed to look sexy but that's the
thing too it's like
why aren't people allowed to change
their mind like why do we have to hold
them
to what they believed in five years ago
reinvention baby
madonna's career we changed i tried
reinvention and i had to actually
go back on that do you remember when i
was trying to be a cowgirl you were so
upset i was tennis remember i was tennis
girl
and then yeah this was in the pandemic
these like though those scaled through
fast though they were rapid fire i was
going to do every two weeks in new life
wait i think i met you when you were
your cowgirl phase
yeah yeah you came with a cowboy hat and
everything and i was like backwards and
you can see the
the tag i don't remember seeing you in
person in that look
no that's when you i wasn't allowed to
see you you were only hugging kesha and
oh my god that is you tried to hug me at
one party
and i don't want to be hugged and then
kesha
like i she i couldn't stop kesha she was
hugging me and i just had to go with it
because she's famous no it's not because
she's famous you're projecting i would
not do that
to be fair she has been to the galapagos
islands and that's a big plus with me
and i would hug kesha
just i still want to take her hug away
she's like ew where did she go
go to an island i can't wait till we
kidnap you and take you to beautiful
places that you have to love
what if esther didn't come back what if
we took you to a place you thought you
weren't gonna lie
and i got kidnapped and you shouldn't go
home if you got
like you getting kidnapped is so funny
they'd be so disappointed
you'd be the most demanding kidnap
victim i know they'd be waiting on your
hand and foot
you would get them too too somehow
what's that benicio del toro one right
oh
uh
she breastfed her baby till he was 10
right yeah he was in barry's boot camp
next to her
breastfeeding no yeah he did floor while
she did and she went backwards so he
could breastfeed while he was doing
you're lying
of course i'm lying but you've been with
him for a long time well i believe
people when they say things to me
is that bad in the comedy world yes 100
but it is why you're here they said they
believed in you you can do this
no but in my barry's boot camp class she
was there and the sun was outside the
window and aft like
every five minutes she ran outside and
gave him a kiss is that not your dream
it's my dream you're sitting outside and
your mom comes and kisses you and goes
back in well yeah you know
when i was little i my mom couldn't
leave ballet like i had to see her in
the window of the studio
or i would freak out so she had to stand
there and just like stare at the whole
do you understand your power no i'm
realizing my power now too i realized
that my whole family was terrified of me
and i was in control of the whole thing
really that's what you are 100 wait
that's interesting
you controlled the whole like i don't
think i did
they were so afraid of what would happen
if you got upset that they were like
all right you can sit and stare at your
daughter
it's weird but yes your mom's just like
so nice just
[Music]
you guys we should probably acknowledge
what we're doing today and why are we
dressed the way we are i'm transitioning
i mean i'm going to prom annie you've
never been to a prom
they wouldn't let me they didn't let the
juvenile delinquents go they figured
we'd all
pop out babies in the bathroom and um
today is actually jules's prom it's
rudy's problem so exciting
and um i that's why we're dressed the
way we are today
this is my actual school prom dress
and you guys can't see this but i'm
unable to zip the back
i would hope so no i mean who it weighs
the same
if you're at your high school weight we
have issues you have an eating disorder
because
you're never naturally you're like that
high school skin you have a different
metabolism
yeah but i mean it's almost there i'm
just saying it's very good the zipper is
broken
the zipper is broken it's broken it can
zip oh it smells
like your muffin top popped it out no no
i can still fit in it this this
outfit is from like four years ago and
it's not zipping from here about mitzvah
this is how i've never seen more of a
bat mitzvah in my life
it's appropriate because it's like cute
but it is like i just didn't have any dr
i don't wear dresses so this was the
best i could do for prom
me neither but you knew i'd take the
swing annie um i think that you look
extremely hot and it's time for
my man to put on my corsage on me i will
and
esther don't like squirt while i'm doing
this well you know i'm your dream guy
right now
no you really do look like a hot guy
vampire
like you really look like taylor hansen
now
wait i actually was thinking that this
phenomenon that's happening right now to
you guys is what happened in middle
school when guys were
were like you look like taylor hansen
but they were into me so they were like
jerking off
to like this hybrid man woman thing
oh this just goes on your wrist i
thought they oh goes pinned onto the guy
they had panda the boutonniere goes on
the man thank you
you have to [ __ ] me if i do this guys
when they slide this on it's like i'm
taking your virginity i'm a yesterday
guy
it's not always banging tonight we're
for sure banging tonight
[Laughter]
no no did you use the scraper
tongue scraper i yeah i can see your
bear tit
it's because it's hairy did you know
that i clogged the toilet at my prom
annie you have to put her massage no
wait you clogged the toilet at your prom
well i guess technically it was after
prom i clogged it in the hotel room that
me and my boyfriend were staying in
you guys had a hotel room yeah isn't it
weird how parents allow that wait
parents allow that
yes i didn't know this well my high
school boyfriend slept over my house all
the time
so it wasn't like door open or a shot
uh shut do they make your house in the
morning
no oh [ __ ] i had to sneak all over town
like either the place is the amount of
strange places i've had sex because
you know the door had to be open if a
boy was over
even if the boy was there's no way my
dad would allow a boy over anyway so
um i'd have to sneak him in we'd [ __ ] in
the garage the baseball diamond
the bullpen i mean it was just the
strangest places
anywhere there was a cut we do it does
that like now as an adult do you like
doing it in strange places no
of course not i don't that's what i
don't understand people that want to do
sex in a weird place thank you sir
they want to do sex in a weird place i'm
like why would you want anything other
than a bed
i used to love banging in bathrooms like
that was like
[ __ ] i don't know why this is when i was
a drunk obviously but when i would go to
santa fe i would do like a tour
of i go back to visit and i do like a
tour of the bathrooms i banged in and
like tagged the guy you stuck up with
there were nice ones with little like
shelf windows and stuff when i did those
it was always just for the thrill and
not for the actual vaginal pleasure
are you standing up do you stand up no
no
they would sit on the um they come sit
on the
sink like it would be like one of those
sinks um
there was a nice one but it was usually
when i was working honestly i was a
waitress and then i was hooking up with
this guy that was a bartender
at the bar like a couple buildings down
and we would go we would like swap these
on our breaks and go bang in the
bathrooms
did you get a thrill like did you i got
pints of jaeger jaeger by the plane
did you like love it or like
it was really fun it was very fun fun
but doesn't feel you know i didn't come
from that
no one comes well yeah well no girls
come from that but i like if i was just
in a bathroom like sitting on a dirty
sink
like i feel like everything would just
that would be dry
yeah even like having sex in the pool
same thing it's
trying to die just waiting to happen i
have tried me too
in water it doesn't work can i ask why
was it because you watched slim fan
no well that probably seemed that early
on
but no i i there's like a friction
there's like a chem
um is it physics yeah i think there's
like a law of physics why what
underwater sex doesn't work
well it like replaces your natural lube
with a lube that doesn't actually like
chlorine vagina either yeah or like
shower sex then it's like which one of
us is under the water i don't want to be
cold
well we know who's under the water
pesters an under i mean where else have
you had sex that's weird
a lot of bathrooms a lot of bathrooms
not just bathrooms but a lot of fashion
there's like it's terrible too it's like
back in the day like this is so funny
but it's
disgusting it is horrible i wonder if
you have a strong immune system because
of that
my [ __ ] can take some germs it can
fight off colds
really can i want to talk more about
prom yeah and i want to know why you
clog the toilet
also if you don't do a joke on stage
about how you clogged the toilet and
you're like it wasn't a baby
you have to go um you're right i so i
went to two proms i went to
because my boyfriend in high school my
high school sweetheart
who's blocked me on all social media um
he was a year older than me so i went to
his senior prom with him
and then the next year when i was a
senior i went with my best guy friend
um and you know
clogged the toilet just the typical had
to use the toilet
is that why he blocked you no he blocked
you like you blocked that toilet from
going down
but um yeah you know we went with his
group of friends because it was his prom
and it was fine i didn't know anyone at
that prom because i didn't know that
class very well
i i don't know i don't understand like
the myth the myth behind prom i think
it's just
it's just a party with a dj it's like a
bar mitzvah it's just a reason to get
cute with friends
it seems like disappoint it would be
disappointing it seems like the
there's a lot of build up and i mean
i've had to tell myself that because i
didn't get to go i'm like it would have
said
but also as someone that was like so i
mean i can
i could go to like a dance club and
dance a little bit now
but back in the day i really like when i
would go to school dances you know i was
like in the corner with people like
[ __ ] losers
because we just couldn't dance it wasn't
like we just had to play cool
you know what here's what life's about
i'm gonna tell you
it's about being with the right group of
people it doesn't matter the activity
but if you're with people who you have
that
[ __ ] yeah connection with where anything
can be fun
and i don't think i ever had like a prom
neither of those problems without
that group which like i feel like i have
those people in my life now
they might be in this room um george i'm
looking at you
and i was like this [ __ ] is definitely
leaving me out i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
her
um so i do think that like i never went
with that right group
and i would love to i would love to do
it all over again with the right group
of people
let's go should we crash a prom well
it's 50 dollars for chaperones to get
into jules's prom
that is so disgusting wait you can be a
chaperone oh yeah prom cost money
no it's disgusting for a shopper be like
i'm going to pay 50
to hang out with a bunch of kids and
dress wait anyone can just go anyone
anyone can just like we could crash it
we could be like hey fifty dollars we're
chaperones of
but um i tried to offer to drive her to
prom i was like
let me drive you she was like no [ __ ]
taking an uber like i'm not getting into
that production what a [ __ ] chance
i'm showing up in that three-door prius
where is her prom not too far um at
water you know what's funny though
the reason i know i am one of those
friends to you is the most fun we've had
is like at 7 11 getting slurpee
yeah we've never had fun i mean not that
we don't have fun at the events but the
events are never the fun time it's
always like
getting ready getting ready is my
favorite part about going that was the
only reason i think i truly still
um fantasize about vegas with girls is
just getting ready and being silly in
the hotel room and you know
playing what do you call it what do you
americans call it slap butt
what is that like puss a slap ass what
do you call it george
no one knows when you're just fooling
around with the boys
with the boys grab ass she's like you
know when you're following around with
them wait you're getting ready with your
girls and then boys
when you're just playing grab ass with
your girls that's a colloquial term
colloquial it's a word that i've heard
before and i'm not sure of uh getting
ready with the girls in the hotel room
i think the important part for esther to
really
face the picture allow get into her head
is that
when we do go to vegas she's gonna grab
your ass so just be happy great
that's fine i love that when i went to
vegas with my friend caroline goldfarb
and super funny and we went to see
brittany
and getting i do like the most vivid
memory i have is us getting ready in the
hotel
yeah the build up is the best part like
even when you make out with a boy
the kiss itself is not fun the build up
to the case is the best that threesome
story i told you with our unnamed
friends
yeah i still don't know who that is
you're gonna love it it's actually
really good it's really
a brand answer like none of these people
will ever guess it unless they were at
any of the shows that i was just
fully saying her name and then she was
like can you stop saying my name
it just didn't occur to me i was like i
told my agent i was like is that bad
um but we i
the fondest memories really getting
ready we're cracking up
the whole thing for the threesome well
it was it was going to be us like
banging dudes next to each other
um and then the guy left so yeah it was
like we're gonna go pick up we're gonna
go get some dick
you start outfits so you're really
you were really down with the like [ __ ]
a stranger
yeah i'm just i think it's everything
i've done has been horrible there's one
time it was
it's god's doing that we didn't meet
earlier in life because i think we would
have both been
dead and raped in a ditch yeah together
or we would have holding hands
me shuffling you shoveling it
dave comes and shovels for you dave
would never help me in a crime
i already know that he would turn you in
yes ask her i want to know the breakdown
of your prom outfits and did you
put a lot of thought into it um i
actually didn't
so i always was like the contrarian
growing up so
if all the girls were like focused on
their prom like i would be like i'll
just do it last minute like i got my
dress like right before
like probably like two days before and
same with like shoes or whatever
i had a bcbg strapless
um like bright
green turquoisey like so
two thousands it would probably kill
right now
it would absolutely kill that's where
they're selling right now no it was like
so two thousand we had like kind of
some frilliness and like a you know a
ruche is that what it's like
and that was my for the first prom with
the i think yeah
and then the next one i went marilyn
monroe very similar to yours i
found like the most marilyn monroe white
dress i could find and that's what i
wore
oh white dress is a problem i mean i it
does look like you are ordained to marry
me and
collect you i do look like a bride
i've never been more excited
about a product that we've endorsed on
this podcast
bobby plays this game with me where he
pins me down
and he just likes to spread my cheeks as
far apart as possible
so the air um touches my [ __ ] and i
gotta tell you guys it actually kind of
feels a little good but i don't even
need him for that anymore i can just
do it myself with this hands-free
hands-free with this exposed
booty tape it's the world's first
hands-free
butt cheek spreader that holds yours and
your partner's butt cheeks open for you
so you can enjoy
deeper penetration easy access and
maximum exposure
this is amazing for bobby and i just
want to say and i can't wait to call him
in hungary
and show him this product it's going to
make him hungry let's just say that
how would you put it in there okay you
just spread like and get ready
so each one of these so this goes on one
cheek
and this goes on the other cheek and you
just pull the tape apart i can't wait to
try this as soon as this prom dress goes
off
comes off it's body safe too unlike
other tapes that are not made for skin
which can contain harmful chemicals
but give the gift of butt spreading fun
on a date night taking doggie to the
next level it's real hot for folks
dabbling in some kink like myself power
play bondage bdsm role playing it also
makes a great gift idea for your ass
connoisseur friends and dirty hilarious
also you can tape if you're like me you
can tape your hemorrhoid to the side
there's a lot of value in this product
lots of different options but
you guys like honestly if i got this for
christmas or for a birthday there is not
a better
present there isn't there's not a better
present it's time to split the peach
guys
always for your next date night
adventure get yours at exposedtape.com
promo code bath girls for 10 off and
don't forget to follow them on instagram
at couples co products that's
at couple co products expose tape.com
promo code bathgirls for your 10 off
what interferes with your happiness you
know sometimes when my
ass tape gets like caught on my ass hair
i mean annie and i have different
problems but for me depression and
anxiety is a real
detriment to my life i have really not
that many problems
some say anger i don't know i have
anxiety
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can connect in a safe and private
online environment send a message to
your counselor anytime and you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule
weekly video or phone sessions all
without ever having to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
which is really important by the way
cause some sometimes it's not a match
it's not a match pheromones are off
everything's off and it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling and financial aid is
available the service is available for
clients worldwide
and they have licensed professional
counselors who are specialized in
depression stress
anxiety lgbt matters family conflicts
all of the
all of the things unlike in this
friendship what you share is
confidential
super confidential it's also convenient
professional affordable and you can
check out the testimonials posted daily
on their site
in fact so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
we want you to start living a happier
life today as a listener you'll get
10 off your first month by visiting our
sponsor
at betterhelp.com bloodbath
join over one million people who have
taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp h-e-l-p
dot com slash bloodbath
well my thing was i didn't have a lot of
money in high school my mom my parents
did not have a lot of money
we didn't have a car i had the mta bus
pass
so um i did too did not have
plans for a dress because i was like oh
i could just go to the the mall and find
something like that's 25
didn't find one yeah but my mom was so
sweet um she saw that i was like really
struggling
and so three days before prom she was
like let's pay for a seamstress
i think that's like the cheapest route
and get what you want and i tore
out this picture of halle berry um at
one of like uh her red carpet events and
it was a purple dress
and i went to the seamstress and i said
make me a replica of this
wait really it wasn't it wasn't it was
days before too
wait so you had a custom prom dress i
did and my mom just
like taken out of her savings a little
savings that she had and she was like
it's okay it's like a special day holy
[ __ ] and then
um we didn't quite get the replica
because the dress was actually purple
but it was like this lady was like
this cloth is actually cheaper so let's
go with this cloth
oh it's all the way to the right the top
right top top right that one
it was supposed to be that that's
beautiful
it does this actually looks like it but
kind of
kind of is this the one that got made
for you yeah oh it's so cute this is
from high school
and it's supposed to be that yes it's
supposed to be that
um but um and it's backless you could
wear this
on your wedding it's just not gonna
happen
because um there's everything's broken
it's dirty i thought you were gonna have
like a naked
it's a little too dirty for her wedding
she has a little too dirty have you seen
the groom
but my date was jason bullock he was
really hot and he was my boyfriend
so i had to pay 50 bucks today i had to
pay 50 bucks to be my chaperone
so i okay so i didn't get to go to prom
because of the juvenile delinquent stuff
and then i had another opportunity where
max my twin brother who
i skipped up in high school what yeah i
skipped eighth grade i was in
kindergarten two years skipped eighth
grade it's true why did you skip eighth
grade like
you just like nobody noticed i just said
can i be in the upper school
if they were they were not their
teachers they were they'd have sex with
us
you just chose to i just said can i be
in the upper school they didn't have
great it was like
middle school and upper school it worked
out then because weren't you and max
held back that person yes
you know it is called high school well
yes i do know that
and we were high do you guys want to see
jules's dress for prom
yeah she's not made up but we could
probably i feel like esther this dress
would be a hit with you
i can't wait you know what i'm a little
disappointed about your
prom description what i kind of was
hoping you were one of those girls that
got
went got the super done prom hair with
like the tight curls
i probably did have an updo yeah did you
do the tendrils in the front
no i was a little bit past that like i
was
that was a little before my time like i
think my sister had that ooh i boy did i
have the tendrils
and i had the crimped hair because i
went to two proms as well
but my senior prom that's the only
regret i have is that i
try to do i don't know how to do my
makeup so i did all white eyeshadow and
that made my eyes
look this small and my hair was crimped
and
i already have naturally one eye bigger
than the other so all my prom pictures
was just one eye fully blasted open and
one tiny little eye
well you were winking i was leaking
that's the best emoji
i wish i had been more confident in high
school like i think i was pretty good
but i wish i would have it when it came
to prom done something a little crazier
like
taking my mom as my prom date like i
wish i would have done something that
pissed everybody off
or like how you were one of those people
that choreographed a dance in the middle
of prom by the way i only go off of the
problems i've seen in movies
in the middle wait what was your final
song i have no idea
do you remember no ours was casey and
jojo all my life
that's a good one i i would ask you
annie but well my
camp dance the last song was always
stairway to heaven
it's [ __ ] wait what's a camp dance we
had his dance at camp
you did you went to camp yeah i went to
quaker camp
adult as an adult oh wait i saw the
pictures you were
tweeny i was yeah i went from like 9 to
14.
i um i feel like i just never liked the
traditional parts of high school i was
so into my own
little universe that i built for myself
like the football games drove me crazy
the like prom was meaningless to me i
just was so
like focused on my little world that i
created
and i just didn't care and i i even
though like i stand by doing that i'm
also like well
you know it could have been really nice
to have like that once in a lifetime
experience and
of going to the football game like
participating i think we should crash
jules's prom tonight and to have a redo
and i think we should dance our little
hearts out it's my first problem
and it would be annie's first prom we
could take pictures we didn't have a
school why is george laughing like this
was already planned and that's i'm being
sprung
what oh my god you're so paranoid it's
so funny
is this like a okay what's going on is
this real
i think that we should drop drop some
50s down
chaperone and just tear it up you're all
looking at me
like you're freaking out knew this was
coming
and like if i did this esther
jules would never speak to me again and
also let's be real it would be
like pig's blood from carrie without you
would [ __ ] kill us
by the way my dream is for pigs blood to
fall on you and i know it would be the
worst thing that ever happened to you
but i just want you to know there's a
dream in my heart
that is inappropriate to say here comes
jules with her dress come on in jules
oh my gosh it's tie-dye it is tie-dyed
are you upset they stole your thing
where did you get it the music it's
the brand oh my god do you have a
boyfriend oh you're going to leave
you're
so hot this is so hot now you're
definitely going to beat up esther
oh my god jules that's what you're
saying i feel like an
old lady like i'm like oh my god look at
the prettiest you want to like pinch
your cheek because you know
wait hang on a second so jules you don't
have a date right
that was a choice yes yeah we tried to
offer her some date potentials and she
was like no i'm cool like christy
stefano
really honest or chris let's settle it
um and so what advice would you give to
a shy girl going to prom
in terms of like how you get in on the
dance floor
you i think you just do whatever like or
just own what you're doing you're going
by yourself
you don't have a date like you look
great just
own that because the only thing that
matters is you being confident
so just dance by yourself
she's getting so uncomfortable dancing
like no one's watching
jules also on stand like no one's fan
that's it
you the way you stand the way you're
very like this is not gonna catch you a
dick girl so you gotta stay
it will but it's not it's gonna be
someone that's like i can take advantage
of her
yeah it's not gonna be the dick you want
shoulders up shoulders up
oh god we're here also i don't know if
you know this but
yes up higher
one leg up me up also jules um
you don't know this but we've all paid
our fifty dollars to be your chaperones
tonight
so we'll just we're just going to tear
it up on the dance floor
guess who's going to be in the pictures
with you and that's your day
jules you look so stunning in this dress
i knew you would love it back to you
you look so stunted it's so big
it looks great did you try a bunch on
did you know that's right off online she
was like that's that was the one
then it just fit her body 19.
oh my god all right jules well thank you
for your time we'll see you tonight on
the dance floor
oh my god she's so upset with you do you
have a thong i see your panty line
no wear whatever underwear you want
don't listen to this
grim groomer what do you think she
should do with her hair um wavy
or pin like sleek down oh
sleek i think i feel like the wavy
though goes with the dress
more it's kind of like free spirit
i feel like nine for ninety's sake it
would be sleek with like baroque
and it would clash with the stuff oh
with this with this
yeah with a little so she really has
prom there's really problems
and they all got all the kids got tested
or show their vax cars
oh my god i've thought you meant sexual
asses stds i was like
they're being this open about it they
can just go [ __ ]
freely i'm like this is so unfair we had
to go to bathrooms
can we take a banana break yeah okay
thank god
[Music]
i'm trying to do the prince harry oh
isn't that cute when he does i
do like what did he do it feels like
like kind of fine but also like is she
your doll what did prince harry do
and he always pulls her like hair out of
her eyes or
her inside yeah i think it is really
cute i do think
that um in a strange turn of events he
turned out to be the way hotter brother
i think about this all the time and when
you look at pictures of them when
they're younger
william is hotter and harry is so not
[ __ ] hot
but then now it's like the reverse and
you just feel like you're in bizarro
world how'd this even happen
well i can tell you how it's male part
but male pattern baldness
and it came very early no
i think he his face i don't know what it
is i just think that
he was the cutie and now harry is so
freaking do you know what he really
needs though
is neutral um
a wonderful product he can fly a plane
he's
harry he's been through a lot he dressed
up like a nazi
it's like he's been through so much but
here's what they did i do remember that
here's what
why he's not hot to me anymore he is so
megan's [ __ ] i'm sorry if it's like
illegal to say that
megan listens to this podcast oh that's
right in our in our mind does she really
oh i'm serious i'm serious i was like i
hope she likes what i said about
i could never fantasize about being with
him because he
so belongs to her let's say let's play
it out let's say you were single
okay right and you really have the hops
for harry
and you know you know that things are a
little bit
a little harder he's shown some interest
you guys have flirted in the past you
know there's already natural chemistry
you met at like a caa party
right and you know megan and him best
place to meet people
your agency's party megan and him are on
the rocks
things aren't working out at home and
you sort of have this like
clandestine on the low like flirtation
going on
how would you think how would you react
if megan confronts you is it megan or
megan megan
megan how how there's a megan there's no
world where i would threaten megan
and this is uh harry esther
this is megan and i are done it's you
baby i want to be with you
i am sorry harry i would rather just
stay friends i've seen how you've
publicly
bent over backwards for her you [ __ ] on
your family
like which is hot but it wasn't for me
and i'll never get it out of my mind i
will be so insecure thinking about
everything you did for her and how you
you have to top it for me that it just
wouldn't ever work out between us but i
respectfully
i respectfully declined the offer what
if he immediately like
was like hold on and like called the
queen i was like you stupid [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then with that
what would he have to do to top what he
did for megan
what would he have to do for you murder
and like like and not get away with it
in a way she's easy to get
like go to prison and then you guys
would conjugal visit
then i would be like you know we can do
this and
there's a way i see would you challenge
by all the
girls that would be like obsessed with
them because he's a murderer now
yeah but that would always be well there
will always be tons of women obsessed
with him but i just
for me i need to i need to like know
that your whole history and just know
that like i
i'm like the dominant woman in your life
like for sure
do you get along with people's mothers
that you date yeah
well i get along with my current
mother-in-law not really legally but
that's what you'd call her
but in the past guys parents have
typically hated me
do you play soccer oh my god my high
school boyfriend
oh that's right his parents hated me
they said that remember i went over for
hanukkah dinner
and then the next day he's like my mom
thought it was weird you didn't offer to
help
and i was like i that is weird
that is weird yes sir i'm like you don't
knowing her is not weird but
my mom they [ __ ] me up okay i'm a
victim
i get in trouble like that i'm a victim
i can just clip that
they didn't like my fancy matzah that i
brought like from a really oh so you did
bring
i brought something yeah yeah nobody
seemed to like it
but you know what kind of mother would
be well best suited for you then
asian moms because they want you to do
nothing if you offer to help they'll be
like
what are you like you know they don't
want you to lift the finger
everything is hand and foot served on a
yup although
dave's mom is a very jewish mom and she
the last time we stayed there
really took good care of me and i was
like i i could do this again
i could get used to this so jewish or
asian moms are best suited for yeah
although that was a jew
well that was a converted you mom
but also when your kids in high school
you don't need to like their girlfriend
do you know what i mean it's like
what are the chances they're gonna end
up with their high school sweetheart
that's true well dave's parents
were high school sweethearts so he
always thought like his first girlfriend
was
he was gonna marry her the dave have a
high school sweetheart
no a college sweetheart and does that
like do you like hearing stories about
that
no i i'm really
and she's like seems probably very
lovely but i'm like do you look at her
instagram
no i don't know her instagram but i've
like met her a few times because she's
in our world oh and i yeah
and i'm just well also she has something
that you'll never have
what a degree and a harvard degree
she like obviously does not give a [ __ ]
about me
but i have like my own secret mental
relationship with her
like it's so pathetic i i do understand
pathetic you know what you do you pull a
bobby you know what bobby does
he follows every single one of my exes
on instagram
oh all of them why he i have no
idea yes it's dominance no i don't know
if it's dominance
or mental just psychopathy like it is
honestly he's like
all of them babe what's so-and-so's
instagram handle why do you need to know
that i'm gonna follow him
that's so weird no i'm gonna tell you
why it's dominance because bobby
knows he's something special right and
bobby's going i'm gonna take my little
check mark and my
tons of followers and i'm just gonna pop
in and like some of their things and
just
give them the gift of me on their page
god you're right what a narcissist
i love it though it's so funny
let's talk about hello fresh uh i love
it
i got my first order last week it's so
good
i made it came two portions it's i
cooked for todd he was so impressed
it tells you everything to do it tells
you where to manage like how to manage
the time like
first do this at this time or do this
then do that like i didn't burn anything
i made it crusted it's a miracle i made
them this
crusted chicken i made them pork chops
i just look so great i ate one for
breakfast the other day
it's so good it's so good with
hellofresh you get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right to your door
skip trips to the grocery store and
count on hellofresh to make some
home cooking easy fun and affordable and
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit
try meals ready in 20 minutes or less
lightening prep recipes and quick
breakfasts and lunches
perfect for your busy schedule also
nothing goes bad it's like all portioned
out for you it just takes out any of the
stress
but you still get the feeling of
actually the accomplishment of cooking
the food
hellofresh's fresh ingredients are
sourced directly from growers
and delivered from the farm to your
front door in under a week contact
free of course go to hellofresh.com
bloodbath
12 and use code bloodbath12 for 12
free meals including free shipping go to
hellofresh.com
bloodbath12 and use code bloodbath 12
for 12
free meals including free shipping and
we thank hellofresh america's number one
meal kit
for sponsoring this episode you guys i
am obsessed with magic spoon it's so
good
my safe place finally we can eat cereal
again as adults because then we
abandoned cereal years ago and we
thought
it had to just chock full of sugars and
all the bad things we didn't want on our
body
and what did we like about cereal back
in the day we liked that prize you got
but you know what the prizes was with
magic spoon
magic spoon it's the cereal it is the
prize it's so good
and you can make treats yes magic spoon
has zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving and
only 140 calories as well
it's keto-friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free low-carbon gmo free
and you can build your own box so you
can choose from
different flavors like cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter blueberry and
cinnamon
oh i haven't tried cinnamon yet i'm
excited about that so go to
magicspoon.com
bathgirls to grab a custom bundle of
cereal and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code bath
girls to check out to save five dollars
off your order and magic spoon is so
confident in their product it's backed
with a 100 happiness guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com bathgirls and use the
code bathgirls to save five dollars off
and we thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode
i would never look at todd's
really i would never i don't i just
really why
what do i want to look at like little
kids little kids
like women oh that's right because he's
like no but he likes older girls so
there's
i mean i think i'm the oldest girl that
he's been with but i can't believe you
don't hear i have like your
your curiosity isn't peaked i just i'm
in love i know he loves me i trust him
i feel that way too but actually in the
beginning
no i but in the beginning i was insecure
yeah like i definitely don't check on
anyone now
but yeah in the beginning i was so
insecure i think i just never get that
type of insecure with guys and
it's i have gotten blindly cheated on so
hard because of it like just not even
it just doesn't occur to me just because
i just project
what i am and i would just never have
the energy or the i would feel
how did you find out you were being
cheated on uh one time was i looked at
his
his phone was in my car he was like go
get my phone and i sent him like i made
spoon
it was when before there was a iphone so
i made
i was trying to make spoon emojis so
like with the parentheses and then
an l underneath and i wanted to see if
the spoon came out when i sent it to him
so i was getting the phone and i like
opened it to see if the spoon and it was
like a girl from the night before
and i spent so much time with her my dad
had been in town so i was like what age
was this
twenty one or twenty two so
non-conferences but it was non-comedy
but it was also
when i had first found out i was
allergic to condoms so that was the
thing that pissed me off i'm like dude
i'm raw dogging with you and you're
[ __ ] other girls
like that's so bad and so
um i stayed with him for a little longer
and then
but i made him like call her and say he
had a girl like i was just like dude you
can't
i wasn't mad at her you know i was just
like what the hell is this
i got cheated on again by my
ex-boyfriend i had like a thing where my
ex-boyfriend was dating a new girl who
like attacked me on instagram
what'd she say she was like nobody wants
your damaged [ __ ] you stupid raped
[ __ ] like [ __ ] like that
i was like oh my god i was like i had to
get her fired she like worked at the co
it was just like so crazy it was
so like out of nowhere it was this guy i
had broken up with and wanted to break
up with for so long that was like i was
not
i still had like a friendship connection
with him but i was not like trying to
[ __ ] be his girlfriend or anything
just like jesus and um i didn't even
know he had a girl like this popped out
of nowhere like he didn't tell me he had
a girlfriend like he was keeping her a
secret
but anyway that doesn't matter it was an
upsetting moment but
don't care now i see that girl sometimes
and have no ill will but
um i don't want to hang out but i'm like
ooh you're not safe
but enjoy your life and here do you want
some pretzels
she came up to me once and was like oh
my god you're not going to believe it
he cheated on me too so i got payback
and i was like
cheated on you too i was like did you
cheat on me
how did how did they say it how you how
you get them is how you lose them
if you if you acquire a man in a
cheating situation
you're going to lose them to a cheating
situation they always say so she was
going to lose him anyway she acquired
him
cheating on you so she he's going to
cheat but how funny is that i had no
clue and i also did not care i was like
that would have been so helpful that
knowledge i would maybe
break up with them easier and faster i
hate that she wanted to align herself
with you
after the fact because she wants my
clout yes
which is why she was attacking me to
begin with that was like it's pronounced
[ __ ]
no mine's out so it's called a clout
it's here you can't see it look guys
look at my [ __ ]
my side clip oh my god
um we're a good team that's my perfect
notice how i won't give you an open palm
you won't do anything that's like what i
want
you're just such an annoying kesha comes
in she's like high five
that's not true i don't like hugging
anyone
and you know that everyone knows that
about me
but sometimes i'll be like okay i have
embraced you i've stroked your head
i've gone to every taping of your
special
i've i've caressed you yeah i like to be
held
i don't like to be hugged esther do you
you are so annoying
imagine being another person that's not
you meeting you
i like to be held and not hugged [ __ ]
you
what are you talking about it doesn't
make sense
this reminds you of the time i tried to
convince dave that there's a difference
between a present and a gift
oh my god
and i like stuck too please give us give
us the
the so i said that a present is a
surprise
like a random surprise and a gift is
like for a holiday
that it was planned and like i just
completely like he still makes fun of me
for this but i
was so serious and like totally like
sold
my story well you know what your present
is that you're very annoying
esther do you think you'd be an easy
person to cheat on since annie says
she's an anime oh are you kidding me
no she's got trackers on every boyfriend
she's ever had
no i like she knows like they're banging
the old ones are banging
she knows what grocery stores are going
to
mean i it that's hard to say though
because it's like
dave does go out to like 5 a.m
do you have a ring camera strap oh my
god what if when he says i'm going to
poke her he means like i'm going to
poke her he's just been telling me he
was being very open you're in an open
relationship you didn't realize
um no i have tracking on everybody in my
life it's just
like i'm just listen she doesn't you
i never gave it to you i know what if
you were like no i got it
[Laughter]
yeah i i've always been a tracking type
i can't do it i can't be tracked it's
very upsetting to me yeah you're
very proud you repel tracking i really
hate it
being tracked or tracking being tracked
i couldn't i don't know what attracted
you you don't like any kind of
um like trolls no
like you it's hard to it's hard to track
you down and like
i feel like if i said i feel like you
want to hang out with me but if i said
hey do you want to hang out today at
three
you'd be like really stressed out and
like wouldn't want to well because it
would be f
it would be 2 45 when it would be 2 45
and it would be like i would be telling
you like well i'm hopping in the shower
right now you'll be like
can you meet up in two minutes i can i
shower and then be like why do you need
a shower and i'm like oh my god
well played
no i try i rush to get to you on time i
try to get to you on time but it can't
be
it's like the time has to have been
planned and enough for me to schedule my
time through the day
because i have time management
challenges
i have time management i thought this is
something i
have just started focusing on it for me
it's not time management it's um
it's we're trying to figure out if it's
ocd
or if it's something else but um i don't
have a rigid
um feeling about time but there's
something that i do
that my therapist is still trying to
like help me figure out
is i cannot be there a minute early
it drives me crazy i have to play this
game where i
i do like i take my last steps in the
stairs to come into this room
right at four not i'm
terrified of being early why and she was
like well
it has a lot to do with being forced as
an athlete
it's like i don't want to be at that
pool a minute earlier than i have to i
don't want to be in a place
and work a minute harder than i have to
when time was taken from you so it's
like
the part that's yours is gonna every
second is gonna be that makes sense
everybody
i was like that with my like jobs you
know with
johnny rockets equinox press juicery i
would say
you worked at equinox hell yeah i worked
at l.a fitness
really you were way fancier than us i
know i only worked there so obviously
because i wanted to work out there and i
knew that i could never afford it how
many times did you work out
not a lot because you're at work you
don't want to be there like you want to
stay
yeah everyone was so hot did you bring
the little towels
no i didn't bring i wasn't like the
towel girl i worked the front desk
how was that for you i feel like it was
fine i feel like you could be good at
customer service yeah
if people were watching you there was
like a camera on you i was like i
i never hated any of those jobs i guess
and we move towards the end but
like if you're on a break i understand
you
i sit you sit in the car until the very
last but i'm surprised that you apply
that to hear it it's like
trauma everything like it's basically
um it's twofold i come from a country
where there isn't a whole lot of
rigidity
around time or like the pressures of
being like super punctual outside of
like
school is what i'm saying like i'm
always i show up to school on time and
things like that but if i have a choice
it's one of those things that i don't
prioritize and i don't get stressed out
as well if people are late um i get
stressed out when people are early
like it esther i cannot ask george
there's nothing that
pisses me off more than when we have a
tiger belly episode and someone shows up
15 minutes early yeah take a step buster
i feel
i start sweating i get stressed out
it is such a mental inconvenience for me
and i'm trying to like get over this
hurdle of
why do i have a panic attack when people
show up early
because i was like you know what you're
you're asian right so you have asian
mother in you too
right so you feel like you should be
here like taking this is my guess
yeah you should be taking care of your
guests and stuff so when they come early
it's like your job starts early
even though it does it doesn't have to
they can wait is that true though
i think that's part of it my job starts
early it's like 15 more minutes than i
have to do
then and it's not to say that i don't
like doing the podcast it's just
but it's still work is work yeah you
know
and when i could be picking my boogers
upstairs
and just waiting those 50 minutes save
for the show
you know and pick up on the camera
yeah but i know that everyone has their
own idea of time and i know like i have
people in my life who are so like
punctual and like
we just don't like carry on with time in
the same way but my therapist said
something interesting she's like
no one is right like the punctual one
isn't right the early one isn't right
the late one isn't right it's really
around
your um idea of time so it's like you
either learn to negotiate with people
and tell them look
i hate showing up early it brings me
anxiety you talk to the person who hates
being late
and you come up with a compromise mm-hmm
but i
do not compromise sometimes sometimes
i'm really late you never know what
you're gonna get with this guy
i disagree that there is a right answer
because the reason that i get freaked
out if i'm late
is that other people are waiting for you
and
that's like rude and also i think too
because like in acting like you can't be
late because then you'll like cost the
production money
so to me like that's just how i view
things i mean i'm that's something to
say that i'm never late to anything
but the rude the feeling of being having
people wait is rude it's the same
feeling i get when people arrive early
so it's either cultural or something
that stems from something
so she's more exp saying that the idea
of time and the rigidity around it
is really all just [ __ ] and it's an
anxiety thing too i think it's like
whichever way
yeah so my anxiety is the opposite of
her anxiety like regarding like time and
stuff i'll tell you the reason it's so
annoying to be stuck
in traffic on the way it's because
because i live far away now it's like
you're you have the anxiety of lateness
for the entire
trip yeah and it's just getting later
and you're like how did it get
like you can't move i do not like being
on uh
early either wow and i'm trying it's
[ __ ]
boring it's uh it's like it's just not i
like to i like
coming in with energy to things like i
just came from another thing you know
but but also it i'm not a dick like i
would never show up to some place like
an hour late or 30 minutes late or
you know like i have like maybe a five
six minute window
if i am late but but that's it like i'm
not an [ __ ]
like i know that some people are like
two hours late to something like on set
and you're like where the [ __ ] were you
one of my professors in college said
that being late
is an underlying issue with authority
where you're like time is not going to
tell me
i think you have that i have that i have
that yeah i have you think i have it
with you because you
do try to be an authority it's the most
crazy thing i
can't believe it when you you're like a
dictator i'm like who is this [ __ ]
the king of hollywood is
telling me i have to be somewhere right
now sometimes you'll ask me places where
i'm like it physically
is impossible and then i want to make it
work
so then i like and so then i'm feeling
guilty because i want to please you and
then i'm just like i'm going to [ __ ]
kill her i'm driving i'm like i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill this [ __ ]
i was thinking something when i was
going in her bathroom and i was seeing
all of the
bobby and kalila paintings and all of
the like couple
fan art yeah is it fan art fan art yeah
i was thinking you guys kind of can't
break up
no we can't also i feel really bad
art you know though but here's the thing
it depends what kind of girl
he gets with after me she'd have to be
super understanding very adult-like and
just super chill because
um i remember when he you know he used
to date sarah who's a who's a comic you
guys know her
she's really funny she's so funny and um
when i would see these framed photos of
the both of them like being funny
together
my my urge was never to throw it away
because like i i actually genuinely
think she's funny so we still have all
those photos so i think
whoever if if we ever break up he has to
get with someone
similar to me in that sense where it's
like i cannot compete with that past of
his and just accept it
and live with it what if it was jules oh
stop what if he would
you're so wow you said someone like you
it's your cousin
this is my knees she's my baby niece wow
you got full chomo
what's chomo um child molester
our perpetrators we become the
perpetrator we gave them cute names
[Laughter]
why are your spoons so long oh they're
asian spoons
what do you mean they use them as
chopsticks too no they don't flip them
over yeah you flip them over
no you don't not no i don't i actually
don't know why they don't
know she misses her dog that's because
you only have baby spoons in your house
esther
oh yeah that's true we use we don't and
also
we don't use metal honestly look how big
that spoon is in her hand
what do you use wood we use bamboo
i feel so bad i'm talking about dave so
much but
he can't stand the feeling of metal in
his mouth
oh i get that my sister cannot stand the
when the spoon clangs on my teeth by
accident
it drives i have to say once you get
used to non-metal it's pretty good
i just i'm finally seeing where you guys
are aligned
you guys are made for each other it's
really great
i wish you would have known it a few
years sooner than i did but annie so
you were tennis girl you were cowgirl
you went through a different madonna
phases during the pandemic
what is up with you learning how to play
the recorder
and why the recorder i went to summer
school class for recorder i play the
recorder you play the recorder
yeah what are you what's going on are we
starting a band
i would love to start a recording what's
going on here well i
have to learn it i just got it it just
sits in my drawer too bad for you
i'm only like the only thing i can play
are tambourines that's so
tambourine and recorder band what our
live show is getting so good right now
by the way
what made you get a recorder i was like
i need to figure out i want to teach
myself things
i want to learn things and i was like i
want to learn an instrument
obviously the recorder is easy because
they make second graders
learn it so i ordered a recorder and i
have
just blown it into going like this and
randy like
like howls with it and so i never
because it's so cute i've never actually
felt
i bet there's youtube tutorials yeah i
think i could learn very easily yeah
i've never even taken that second step i
just undid the box
i can play that song
i saw that in ice capades once my dad
took me to ice skates i saw
what's ice what it's like it's like
ice skating
show yeah oh that's like disney on ice
yeah it was like disneyland
yeah it was really cool and they did
like did it and then you know it's like
i was sitting at a bar or something so
it was like they
they brought a bar out with seats and
then there was like
this like ice skater like she like got
up on the seat and was like spinning and
then like
it was great and then he also took me
took me to see david copperfield because
he would get the boys always one of my
brothers always wanted to go see sports
and my dad worked at the university of
pennsylvania and in the finance
department so the banks would would give
they would have three seats
that they just owned for the season and
they would give like those to different
people in different departments so my
dad would get them and he would only be
able to take my brothers
and i didn't really like want to see the
sports i just wanted the funnel cake but
so then he would take me to like make up
for it he would take me to like
see magic and [ __ ] i love nachos at a
ball game
the best is peanuts at dodger stadium
and you just
throw all the shelves onto oh peanuts
with abandon where you can just throw
everything
around five bags per nine innings
it really is fun because there's the
activity of doing it you feel like
you're doing the exercise to burn off
the
wait i wonder if anyone out there
listening knows of this restaurant but
there was this restaurant like out
way in the suburbs of illinois of
chicago like
way further out like where from where i
lived and it was a restaurant where
you'd go there and the floors would be
covered in peanut shells
and every table had like a bowl of
peanuts and that was just the vibe there
you just got to eat peanuts and throw
the shell on the [ __ ] floor of the
restaurant was so
fun who knows this place out there
chicagoland dodger stadium also allows
that yeah also
you know who i met the other day at the
dodger game george do you know roger the
peanut man
roger a dodger roger a dodger he's a
peanut man i made jules take a picture
with him because i was just
short he was now he's probably got to be
like close to 80.
but he still sells peanuts and like he
still throws them he used to do he used
to do like tricks when he would throw
peanuts at people like he's been doing
it since he was younger
roger owens there yeah he's only in his
late 70s he's been slinging peanuts
since he was 15 years old
he's my happiness goal when you see this
man
everything about him is joy he loves
what he does
he's such a i don't know like he just
exudes so much
joy and i'm i always think to myself
like if i ever want to get to a place of
enlightenment i think about roger the
peanut man yeah i think they sell them
or they're free
no he sells them you have to pay for
peanuts that's what a job is
i'm just trying to figure out what's so
fun about it he
like okay so this is what i would guess
he found a thing that he likes to do
okay which is like
peanuts throw them out but he throws him
a certain way
yeah it's probably fun everyone's
looking he's doing his little
entertainment thing that's like a
performance
he found a need people want the [ __ ]
peanuts okay
so he go he gets to go to this place and
have this give this service to people
that they want
and he does it with his own flair and he
can be in the moment of those
it's the same steps every time but it's
different people like that's fun
and he tells people he's like i used to
be able to throw it this way because
he's older now so he can't like he
doesn't have his fancy moves
but um i don't know like i'm just really
i really adore
roger the peanut man i want to meet him
we should have him on first guest
can anyone go to the dodgers stadium and
sell a product or is this like
oh my gosh oh my god
what do you what do you have in mind
um yeah you can maybe try during the
seventh inning stretch just do a side
hustle
what would you sell i mean the only
thing i have to sell is
my clothing line and your body no that's
your body
hey let's do a question guys from our
fans and reminder to the fans you can uh
submit these on anchor there's a link in
all of our uh
audio uploads do you know what i like
about our podcast that when we answer
questions we just make more questions
my question is do you guys get the poop
sweats
like when you have to poop really bad
that you start sweating
or do you get the meat sweats like when
you eat a lot of meat
and you start sweating meat sweats all
the way i know those meat sweats in fact
if i eat
meat um and at night i sweat the whole
night i get meat sweats
in my sleep i sweat so much and just
randomly eat meat that i have no clue if
it's coming from the meat and you
randomly poop
and i do there's a lot of random poops i
don't even know it's there until the
underwear comes off
how long approximately would you say um
you spend
on the toilet when you poo are you a
quick pusher quick wash you're out or
you like to um
um chill and read a book i'm quick
you either know or you you know or you
know
right it's like it's either happening or
it's not
that's a really weird it's such a thing
that every guy i know does
do you think it's their balls get in the
way like clogs their ass
i don't know what it is i think it's
some type of like stuck in a freudian
stage thing where it's like
the anal stage where they like their ass
cheeks spread but they can't really say
it out loud
so they just use the toilet as an excuse
to like open up their [ __ ]
that's the greatest theory i've ever
heard because i just think that's like
the only place they can hear us they
don't hear us talking
but unfortunately yeah yeah but
unfortunately for me i have an open door
bathroom door policy in my home so if
you're shutting the doors open and i am
talking to you
it's a non-stop talking i definitely
don't like when
a man is in the bathroom too long i'm
like let's go buddy
yeah we got [ __ ] to do oh my god bobby
sits there and i can hear
the bidet just squirting like shooting
high pressure water into his ass for 30
minutes and he's going to be getting on
for 30 minutes then he's masturbating
he probably he's getting the anal probe
of it while he's i just can't imagine
it's
pumpkinning like it's probably so raw at
this point
why don't we have them tell us what are
you guys doing are you masturbating are
you avoiding us
or does is your body just in a shape
where it takes a long time for the [ __ ]
to come out
let us know in the comments don't be
crude be just
medical about it be medical all right
next question my question is if each of
you
could describe all three of you with one
word what would it be
slugs covered it pretty well okay i have
one word for both
i think it's one word that covers all
three of us oh all three of us
oh that's what i thought i have a word
for annie i would call you enigmatic
and i would call you precious because
you're my precious little baby oh
don't give her that that's what she
wants and you're enigmatic like kim
jong-un
what is that matter oh my god that can't
be that good enigmatic like it's like
um george pullup difficult to interpret
mysterious well if you learned my
language maybe
finally
similar to the word puzzling but i feel
like enigmatic is just more than than
mysterious it's something it's like a
dynamic person where you're kind of like
you're never bored
i can never be bored around you annie i
esther's gotten there before
esther there was one episode of my
podcast my husband's head kept getting
further and further away
we were zooming and our head was going
down to the corner
why she was just like i just talked the
entire time and she was just
i don't know i don't think there's one
word what is it unique
unique all of us didn't weren't like the
other people around us growing up
yeah that is true my mom used to always
say i was unique and i was i didn't
understand what she was talking about
i almost don't feel like unique is too
nice i feel like it's like
different unusual
off i like these off kilter but i like
how all of us are i think we all like
stand in our own
light is it a light or her darkness you
know what i mean but for real
look at esther like she's just like with
us present happy look at her
no other person would sit in that chair
like that you guys this has been
a spectacular prom episode i'm fine i'm
so happy that
our our sweet little annie has finally
um
done the whole prom thing i'm so excited
i
like to put my outfit to look like i
already lost my virginity
we can do that you want scissors on the
floor
only fans guys um but thank you guys for
watching we love you guys
click comment subscribe share
uh let us know in the thing women what
do you think guys are doing in the
bathroom
when they're pooping for so long and
guys tell us the truth keep it
pg-13 and we'll see you guys next week
thanks guys
[Music]
you